and seal the edges by crimping with a
fork oh crap
then what's up Chris come on in man
I already did so uh how you been how you
doing how are you great
actually I'm just learning how to make a
gather signs uh or as you Americans like
to say calzones do you want one no I
find calzone a fatty and unnecessary so
you've hit a bit of a rough patch and I
care about you so I just want to make
sure that you're doing okay Chris
honestly I'm great I'm just exploring
whatever fun activity pops into my brain
so we're ordering them a total of thirty
pizzas so let's talk topping sausage
onion and peppers scientifically proven
to be the best toppings nice should we
throw in some salads for a healthy
option Wow don't be such a Jerry Ben
yeah Ben these guys are cops not
ballerinas so we are throwing a little
shindig for the police department
because we're asking them to volunteer a
security during the Harvest Festival
I don't know what it is about big
outdoor gatherings that makes everyone
want a urinate all over everything but
it does and they do okay how about some
calzones calzones are like pizzas but
they're harder to eat they're dumb and
so was that idea seriously this is
embarrassing for you cheap temple
hey nope you know Ben Wyatt from the
state budget office yeah how's it going
hello thank you the party good BJ great
so yeah pizzas dynamite isn't it and you
said it was good Peter
good pizzas good do you work
you know what I like calzones that was
wrong with this guy sorry we'll check in
with you later
take it easy yeah great small talk over
there okay oh what a gorgeous herbaceous
mentally there's been a mistake you've
accidentally given me the food that my
food eats salad is traditionally the
first course at a wedding is a gerbil
marrying a rabbit I'm in charge of food
for the wedding so I brought in pawnees
three best caterers and a panel of
experts chris loves vegetables Ron loves
meat and Tom considers himself a foodie
which apparently means taking instagrams
of food instead of eating it
okay so I liked number one Chris liked
number two and Ron liked number three
Tom what about you cater number ones
presentation was simple yet exhausting
number two's was subtle and provocative
like a coy Dutch woman guarding a dark
secret nothing you're saying is helpful
but number three's told a story a story
from a book I wouldn't read but I would
watch the movie of that's nonsense you
know what I'm gonna go with the first
place I really love that appetizer oh
the mini calzone I wouldn't call it that
it was more like a savory pastry
delicate little dough pocket filled with
tomato sauce cheese and seasoned meat
just a stunning culinary innovation it
was a calzone it was literally just a
small calzone so been white canzoni
glad yes Chris you know there's fast
food hamburgers there's fast food
Mexican there's fast food Chinese blah
blah blah have you ever wondered why
there isn't a fast food option for
Italian food what about pizza pizza
never heard of it that's what people
will be saying in 20 years because pizza
is old news crisp pizza is your
grandfather's calzone I never thought it
that way what I'm talking about is a
portable delicious meal that is its own
container it's a whole new spin on
Italian fast casual dining
amazing now you of all people like this
I'm gonna use low-fat ingredients
game-changer and I will call my new
Italian fast casual eatery the
locale calzone zone that idea is
literally the greatest idea I have ever
heard in my life
that idea is terrible excuse me chief
sorry to interrupt
hey it calzone boy what's up well here's
hoping that that nickname doesn't stick
right but that's not why I'm here
Chris I'm dying I was dying earlier
today and then I died no I'm dead I had
to cancel a date with shauna
malwae-tweep I really like her do you
think just like me dead what is this
it's food poisoning I have it too
I did not sleep for one second last
night and I cracked the bottom of the
toilet bowl God don't say that has
anybody talked to Tom I can't even
imagine but that tiny little man must be
feeling I have voided more than Tom's
body weight in the last 12 hours alone
he might have just disappeared off the
earth we need to call him must reach out
to him I can't do it Ben extension 78 20
whoa it smells like some vomit took a
dump in here what happened we got food
poisoning Tom how do you not have food
poisoning because you didn't eat
anything just take pictures I talked
about the wow factor
not true I hate everything you did are
you sure is there anything that you
didn't oh yeah I didn't eat those stupid
mini calzones have a food rule number
six never eat anything with the sauce
have to dip myself drizzle it on for me
I'm not your maid
the calzones betrayed me never again
guys as God is my witness they're dead
to me alright well Tommy feels great and
I'm about to go eat some lasagna please
hey sorry about the whole mess crisis
has been averted so let's go talk to the
chief
oh I already talked to him they'll give
us the others we need no problem
great what a relief yeah hey are you
hungry
I haven't eaten you know yeah there's a
really great calzone place over an idiot
Ville oh really down on terrible idea
Avenue okay that's weird cuz I thought
it was on beating a dead horse Boulevard
calzones are pointless they're just
pizza that's harder to eat no one likes
them good day sir that's okay
you know I'm just kidding let's go oh
okay the iOW does not mess around which
normally is why I love them but now I'm
on the other side oh my god Ben I gave
them $100 in their annual pledge do you
know how many anti me signs I could buy
you just don't do the pie contest
obviously and then we're just back where
we started then it just seems like I'm
saying I'm better than the women who
bake what should we do should we get a
divorce well how about this what if I
register for the contest I bake the pie
I act as my own wife oh that could work
we sidestep the controversy we refocus
the campaign on to the actual candidate
and then we flip the antiquated
tradition right on its head
exactly
importantly we changed the idea of what
API is I feel like that's not more
important but I like the energy that we
have so let's hear it okay picture this
crust on the bottom filling crust on top
what am i describing a pie no but you're
in the right zone Oh calzone
sure pies are just sweet calzones honey
and I'm good at making calzones you're
amazing I can win this thing of course
you can baby get in there and start
baking talk about the ha way to the
calzone zone did you hear back from
Elise oh yeah we're good the iOW is not
gonna protest us how's your pie I don't
know I didn't make a pie okay how is
your dessert calzone it's ready question
is are they all right our next
contestant is candidate Ben Wyatt's wife
Leslie let's see what mrs. Wyatt has
baked up for us shall we
it's actually MS Knope and actually
right now it's mr. Wyatt Leslie has her
own busy life and I happen to be an
excellent pie maker so we figured we'd
switch it up a bit now pack your
suitcases because we're going to a
little town called Napoli bring me from
what from the tyranny of women we decide
to throw you a pizza party to say
congrats for cracking the case oh my god
you guys see what we got here wait a
second that's not pizza
those are calzone no I did safe to say I
made the right choice
guys
[Applause]
you